Robb's trying to be professional Rob
here tryin he's not trying to be show
Rob he's trying to be a professional Rob
and make a distinction and then this you
didn't like that they all knew that you
lied about the party he's got a he's got
to bring up some show [ __ ] we really Rob
also does professional Rob is more of
the come from the school we don't really
talk about old shed yeah like how are we
supposed to trust this guy Rob if he's
lying about party it's how am I supposed
to get an intern yeah my role as a
member of the Fourth Estate it is my job
to ask hard questions no you're right I
can't
I'm sorry I can't blame you for it and
you wanted to rob might ask questions
that pertain to the panel discussion not
old stuff that would entertain us is the
reason for the panel to ask this
question I also you know not a lot of
friends could come so I could see why
Rob keep going oh yeah about that what
was the second one the clunky yeah what
does the word McClung key it means that
you know Greedo shot first I didn't know
it means and who has a bigger
oh you wanted to be taken serious were
there any old professors or and you want
them just look at look at local boy done
good yeah and you got this [ __ ]
talking about pekka's yep I would have
absolutely hated that the professors are
looking at him like we're never bringing
this joker back yeah yeah I mean I was
gonna say how could Mike being there
hinder you from helping people but
you're right I mean I don't see how
people could take your advice seriously
if you've got some guy in the audience
that you've introduced is your coworker
yeah he said it with the a
each pekus yeah he said it before this
too because I like cut it so what was
the question that he said before this
well no I'm saying he asked he asked the
questions twice and I forgot the pekka's
one
and so you reiterated what was the other
one and he goes Peka Peka ii yeah right
you're a chip guy right of course chip
was there to ask question so what was
actually the question who is the bigger
Pekka
oh we it gets there we go right Rob how
you gonna answer it asked four of them
in a row right and third one who has a
bigger pecker he's trying to cut off
Mike so it's like enough Mike and Mike's
like Lyle two percenters of Lyle tippers
and when the chip Jefferson Potter cast
and now you're stuck in a position Rob I
already know what's going on your brain
and the last thing on earth that you
want to do yeah they say the word the
people in that room are like is this guy
an idiot
yep the rude the word is when you put
the after effects on podcasts like five
minutes after that incoherent babble
yeah I'd like to know more about putting
yourself out there I don't know what
this guy's talk about with pekka's and
pot again
[Laughter]
you